hey everybody i am wonder mike i've come
to say hello to the black white red and
brown the purple and yellow but first i
got to bang bang the boogie to the
boogie you get the point i am a hip-hop
maven okay i
am very excited because my man tom
mcdonald has a new song out and since i
i think i am now the hip-hop
cultural critic here at the daily wire
ben is the rapper at the daily wire i am
the hip-hop cultural critic
i can't wait to listen to it before we
begin this video is sponsored by ring no
matter your home ring has everything you
need to protect it more from them in a
minute first
let's get to the song
lately usa is getting scarier half of
the americans i see all hate america
they hate the cops doing their best to
take care of us and kneel for the flag
insult the soldiers that we're burying
i'm tired of the fishing and complaining
why you living in america if all you do
is hate it you think it's brave to take
a stand against the nation real bravery
is dying for the right so you can say it
dear america what happened to americans
apparently no one's aware cares that
it's embarrassing it's arrogance our
greatest enemy was always slavery and
terrorists and now it's people in the
country trying to burn the heritage i
can't help it i just seem to see the
world different it ain't republicans or
labor roles it's mental illness the
internet is only interested in left
opinion canceled culture's got more
power lately than the first amendment
was it right there this is a really good
point usually i don't like it when
people say this isn't about the left or
the right or the republicans or
democrats because it almost always is
you know but they're just trying to
sound above it all but what what tom is
pointing out here is a real problem with
the left because he says it's not about
the left to right then he goes right
after the left and he says it's about
mental illness
and this is a really good point because
he's saying our greatest threat right
now is is that we hate ourselves it's
not that some enemy is going to come
kill us it's that we're killing
ourselves we're mutilating ourselves i
guess in some cases literally and then
certainly
nationally we are doing that and that is
mental illness that transcends
ideology or the direction you want to
take the country in if you're trying to
destroy your own country something has
gone seriously wrong it doesn't
inevitably go between the republicans
and the democrats but tom is recognizing
this problem actually does transcend
political divisions and we cannot have
that very smart if you don't like it
leave we will not defund police we don't
want no riots in our neighborhoods or
industries we respect freedom of speech
we protect what we believe we don't want
nobody deserve please do not tread on me
in america
your freedom ain't free in america
that's all just starting overseas so
america
can say what we believe
[Music]
america does anybody know what the hell
happened to the patriots let's pause
here i i like this point he's making
he's saying our freedom is what what
allows you to disrespect the flag so
it's actually an incoherent i've made
this point during all the stupid colin
kaepernick stuff
it is an incoherent action to burn the
american flag because you are burning
the american flag
only because you are claiming a first
amendment protection to burn the
american flag but without that flag
which without the country the flag
symbolizes you wouldn't be able to do
that so it's an incoherent action and in
recent decades the supreme court has
ruled that you have a first amendment
right to burn the flag i'm actually not
totally convinced of that and apparently
neither is tom because he's saying you
know look if you're gonna take undertake
this incoherent
psychotic action to to destroy the
country
leave yeah we love our freedom here but
you you really shouldn't have the
freedom to do that kind of that that is
not really the freedom that we're trying
to preserve so
get out of here really
really good point and much smarter than
frankly what a lot of political pundits
are saying who who have this very
abstract ideological view of liberty all
the way to be abused to licentiousness
tom mcdonald actually does not have that
it's funny that you get a more a more
licentious view
of american liberty from buttoned up
think tanks with bow ties than you do
from a professional and very popular
rapper isn't that that's a little bit
strange isn't it he recognizes you've
got to keep the country secure and when
you want to be secure i would strongly
recommend you check out ring
ring with the ring alarm security system
you will just get peace of mind okay i
go on the road a fair bit and when i go
on the road i want to make sure that
sweet little elisa and my cute little
baby june are
secure
i feel a lot better that they can see
who is at the door before they open that
door okay you all know about the the
ring video doorbell where you can see
and speak to whoever is at the door
whether you're in the house whether
you're at the office whether you're on
the other side of the world but with the
ring alarm system you can you can keep
an eye on every inch of your house
indoors outdoors all from a simple app
it's really easy right now for a special
offer go to ring.com knowles k-w-l-e-s
this is the perfect way to start your
ring experience it's very simple to
install i'm not the handiest guy in the
world even i can install it go start
building your ring alarm security kit
today build the system that is right for
your home have it up and running in
minutes ring dot com slash knowles k w l
e s ring dot com slash
knowles
back to the video this nation is so
ashamed and hating itself did everyone
forget that people died to pay for this
ungratefulness united states gave
everything to you just to help i just
want to celebrate thanksgiving with my
family i don't need your help to
understand it was a tragedy can i just
be thankful for my country eating
happily without you trying to guilt me
for the genocide and casualties i can't
help it i just seem to see the world
different pause yeah this is right this
is right uh you know there is a a breed
of conservative like the the berkian
conservative types the conservatives who
are a little less abstract and a little
bit less about five bullet points on a
napkin and what some of them have said
uh you know and they keep coming back to
this as a modern type of meme is look i
just want a grill
okay i just want a grill there's a
there's a kind of meme that's going
around it's based on some clip art of a
guy just saying forget about all this
crazy political stuff i just want a
grill and i just want to have
thanksgiving dinner and i just want to
enjoy that and i don't want everything
to be about some ridiculous revisionist
extreme whiny view of why we all need to
be upset all the time i don't want that
i want to have a nice time with my
family and i want to live my life and i
love my country and it is natural to
love your country patriotism is an
extension love of country is an
extension of your love for your own
family no wonder that we have a decline
in the american family love for the
family we're seeing a lot of the
breakdown of the american family the
redefinition of the family even that is
being deconstructed and what tom is
saying is i want to hear about oh the
genocide or whatever other places don't
do this
it's just the west broadly and america
specifically that does this and it's
sick and it's psychotic and we shouldn't
have it it ain't black or white it's
conflict designed by the system i don't
need your pronouns all i see is men and
women kids are taking pills for fun
while people can't afford prescriptions
if you don't like it go hate it then
don't call it home we don't need no
violence got no time for all your
radicals status quo we're not animals i
won't kneel for the anthem cause the
flag is what i'm standing for
in america just pause it that line is
really good because it kind of
kind of undermines the last 20 years of
republican talking points on how the
only thing we need to do is cut taxes
and cut regulations and privatize
everything because he's saying people
can't afford their prescriptions so
maybe there is something a little weird
about our health care system it's it's a
little weird when kids are overdosing on
opioids but adults who are sick and need
prescriptions need to pay a lot of money
for them and our insurance system is
kind of
kind of byzantine and complex and
inefficient that observation
this is not just gop talking points okay
some people go after tom and say oh it's
you know he's just the republican rapper
i don't think that's not quite true he's
kind of looking past
the the ordinary desiccated political
talking points and seeing the issue for
what it is it's good good juxtaposition
[Music]
then i'll help you back
you can hate the government and still
love the country the fundamental values
of america are country republicans and
liberals are dumb to put it bluntly
their labels that they use to create
chaos and corruption you can know the
history and still be proud of where
you're from every flag around the world
is covered in a little blood we started
out united states divided is what we've
become if home is where the heart is you
should show america some love
in america
your freedom ain't free in america
[Music]
[Music]
yeah this is good this this last point
here
of
our and he's repeated this throughout
the song our freedom is the reason you
can disrespect our flag and so if if the
flag offends you i'll help you pack your
bags i know this sounds
almost crazy to say but i think it's
it's pretty clear from the song he's
hitting on the the central debate on the
american right right now which is is
what's happened to america just some
recent perversion in the past few years
of of the left or
is it was there something
about liberalism the enlightenment
philosophy that had a large effect on
the founding of america though not i
don't think it was the all and all of
the founding that
is created this kind of instability you
know our freedom is the reason you can
disrespect our flag and that that kind
of
at at that time at the founding era
freedom certainly was understood to mean
pursuing virtue the right to do what you
ought to do it didn't include the right
to you know burn the flag and and you
know engage in all sorts of vice and sin
and degeneracy certainly not you just
look at the laws from the era but now
it's kind of because of the weird logic
of this ideology has kind of developed
into that and that we need to stop that
we need there needs to be limits to have
true liberty and if you don't recognize
that then he is more than happy to help
you pack your bags
a lot that's good stuff you know i think
i really enjoy listening to these songs
not because i'm exactly a hip hop or rap
aficionado
you know i'll i'll admit that i'm not
but
the lyrics
the lyrics are good he makes he makes a
good point that tom mcdonald
[Music]
[Music]